[Music]
even two and a half miles down in the
Pacific Ocean there is life but it lives
alongside dark clusters of minerals
needed in the race to Net Zero and it
could be swept up in a new Gold Rush the
international seabed Authority has
called together governments to decide
whether deep sea mining should be
allowed and if so how it should be
regulated I really encourage all
delegations and members face
to stay open and attempt to reach
consensus
we must try to find common ground and
make compromises where we can just
what's at stake is being revealed by
scientists at the Natural History Museum
who've sent robotic submersibles into
the Pacific Abyss they believe they
could be 8 000 new species down there at
least 80 percent of the things that we
bring up are actually they don't have
names we know that we know roughly what
they are we know for example isn't it
kind of dog a sea cucumber and mollusca
a crustacean a shrimp or something like
that but we don't know it doesn't it's
not been described before so it's a new
species of Science deep sea mining would
involve heavy machinery that would
compress the sediment destroying it as a
habitat Greenpeace has called it
Reckless the minerals we need for a
transition to a green economy have to
come from somewhere whether it's in the
deep sea or on land mining does have an
impact but it's the fact that the ocean
is out of sight and out of mind that
makes some environmental groups nervous
the Canadian mining companies expected
to apply for a license to begin
commercial activities off the Pacific
island of nauru within months it says it
will only mine a small area leaving the
rest of the seabed untouched our own
company are moving ahead in a very
transparent and open and cautious manner
so if you look at the land-based mining
industry hasn't had a great record but
this is a very different resource the UK
government says it won't support deep
sea mining without sufficient scientific
evidence of its impact but that research
has barely begun Thomas More Sky News